A Brownsville, Texas,
man with a, quote, extensive rap sheet,
including prior
charges of driving while intoxicated,
has been charged
with eight counts of manslaughter.
Authorities say
that the man was driving an SUV
when he ran a red light,
lost control
and flipped the Range Rover on its side,
striking 18 people
at a bus stop
outside a migrant shelter and killing
eight of them,
most of whom were Venezuelan,
according to authorities.
Video obtained exclusively by CNN
shows a group of people
trying to restrain the man
after the crash.
Witnesses say
he exited his vehicle
and appeared to be impaired.
He seemed to try to run away.
He yelled obscenities, but he was stopped
standing on the Texas-Mexico border.
Migrants are sleeping on the streets
of El Paso
today, a city
under a state of emergency
as the
pandemic era public health rule
that previously allowed the US government
both under Trump and Biden,
to turn away asylum speakers.
The rule, known as Title 42,
is set to expire on Thursday.
It's not just El Paso,
of course, facing the surge.
One organization in Laredo,
Texas, says that it is receiving
250 migrants per day, up from 50 per day
two weeks ago in McAllen, Texas.
One shelter
is getting 400 migrants
a day,
up from 152 weeks ago,
and that a Brownsville, Texas, shelter.
Officials say a couple of weeks ago
they were seeing between 150 to 300
migrants a day.
Now, which 1000 a day?
1000.
CNN Steven Culver is in Mexico
with harrowing stories of migrants
on the other side of the border
at the US southern border.
The struggle is constant.
Illegal crossings like this one
really tough to watch.
Having already clawed
through the barbed wire,
you can see this young woman
frustrated, exhausted,
trying to help the other,
trapped in a web of sharp
metal at the Texas border.
From above,
you might think
they're the only two crossing this day,
but the clothes dangling along the miles
and miles of fencing say otherwise.
For many migrants fleeing countries
like Venezuela,
Nicaragua, Cuba and others,
Ciudad Juarez, Mexico
is the final stop before
trying to claim asylum in the U.S..
Can they wait in places like this?
You can see the sidewalk.
It's full of an encampment.
Different tents.
We've seen thousands
flooding the streets in shelters
at this Mexican border town.
22 year old Janine
Gamez, her husband
and their four year
old little girl,
have camped out here
for three months already.
You're got to stop it on welfare and
get on with them.
She says they're going to cross,
but she doesn't want to do it illegally.
She wants to do it the right way.
And does it no service.
Cuando you don't know when?
No secondo.
In recent weeks, the U.S.
government has rolled out an updated
CBP one app
allowing migrants
north of Mexico City
to register
digitally for a limited number
of interview spots with asylum officers.
No one we've talked to
has been able
to secure an appointment yet.
Danese not sure she'll ever get one.
She lost her phone in a fire
a few weeks back.
But she and others tell me
they've come too far to turn around.
Her young daughter
carries the marks to prove it.
He kept going like era and so
says she has some burns
still on her face from the sun,
from being on top of the train.
The journey
to Juarez from southern Mexico
is hundreds of miles.
So many ride
the rails north on top of freight trains.
We caught up with one
just as it was arriving into Juarez.
Migrants right on top here.
Many of them have made the journey
on this train
alone for more than 8 hours.
A la la la la.
Though he said they were 12 hours
on the train.
He said it was so cold,
everything felt like ice.
My my life was in my mom
and my enemy, hermano,
his whole family here.
And he says, now they are going to stay
and get cleaned up
and prepare to cross into the U.S.
alone or something.
But Leonardo's mom is terrified
to climb down.
I don't know where
they're going to get him out or anything.
Her loved ones at first encouraging,
then telling her, let's go.
Not that they will need by most.
But part of the train
journey north for some
is on what's called
La Bestia,
the Beast or the train of Death.
A ride dangerous
and deadly and often
controlled by cartels.
Hours
making this treacherous trek is scarring.
But imagine days on board.
And as Drinkwater is a commuter.
I was very lucky, she says.
They were four days on this train,
she says.
Horrible, really cold, he says.
Four kids, his wife,
four and a half days on the train.
Yeah.
When they ran out,
I went on myself from there.
I ran across to see.
We see it, but I'm okay.
Clive Palmer. Kazu.
Mama, this is the song American.
He says it's for the American dream.
They're going to try to cross today
another
25 miles under
the hot sun to the border from here.
Precious cargo carried on shoulders
and in hand by Venezuela.
Most end up where we started
at the barbed wire.
The added barrier
rolled out in recent months
by the Texas National Guard.
It does not stop the crossings.
It does slow them a bit.
The young woman uses her jacket
to create a gap
while the other tosses through it
bottles of water and a backpack.
Their only belongings, a quick hug.
And they hurry along.
Likely to turn themselves in to U.S.
officials, more will follow.
And this is where many of them end up.
You can see them camped out behind me.
Not all of them.
This is just a small portion
of the thousands of migrants
that we've seen cross
over here into Ciudad Juarez,
trying to cross ultimately into the U.S..
Here's the thing, Jake, though.
When Thursday comes
and if Title 42 lifts, that by no means
says that all these folks can then
just go through.
In fact, the U.S.
is going to fall back on Title eight,
which means that these folks
will have their chance to claim asylum
to be preliminarily screened,
and for their case
to be potentially heard.
But under Title 42,
they didn't have that.
They were sent back
in some cases immediately.
However, if they go through that title
process, Jake,
and their cases fail
and they don't
have enough to prove asylum,
they can be banned from the U.S.
for some five years.
So in many cases, it's
the stakes are much higher
if they try to cross after Thursday.
All right,
David Culver in Mexico for us, thank
you so much for.